last weekend's European Parliament
elections left several parties
celebrating big gains in Germany the
governing parties performed well a
strong mandate for the country's
so-called grand coalition
Vanessa I'm not really a social democrat
voter but it's not a bad thing for the
grand coalition I think Sweden
unsatisfied to the extent that it
confirmed that the parties interested
and in favor of Europe have got majority
support buzzin dusty document ID
krishnam the Social Democrats make good
gains but not enough I think a coalition
where everyone joins forces isn't all
that important on a European level
Germany's conservatives suffered slight
losses to end up at thirty five point
three percent of the total their junior
coalition partners the Social Democrats
made gains to land at twenty seven point
three percent the newly formed
Euroskeptic afd or alternative for
Germany party made it into the European
Parliament with seven percent of the
vote Euroskeptic parties received
considerable support in neighbouring
countries to the Sui elbows all I'm
worried that we're seeing right wing
parties making such gains around Europe
I don't like that at all dhaka me again
if you're fun as it says as much i see
it primarily as a threat to Europe for
sure once like a sea stack our history
has taught us so much and many Germans
are influenced by that one complete
after the vote Luxembourg's conservative
politician jean-claude juncker is tipped
to be the next EU commission president